Hello, Dog.
Hey, how's it going?
Good afternoon, all good. How about you? How are you?
Awesome.
Wonderful. How is your day going? It's already Friday.
It is. Sorry, I was just removing a notaker.
And you?
Show.
Because I'm a jerk like that.
I was like, where is Natalie? She's not here. Her note taker can't be here.
The.
All that.
Alright.
What's up, Andy?
Hello, how are you?
Good, how are you?
Fantastic.
What is that? I was doing a little research.
Mhm.
The Philippines has its own Memorial Day, but then also kind of observes the US Memorial Day a little bit. Is that right?
Yes.
We do have, we don't have technically a Memorial Day in the Philippines, but we observed it also because it's part of the ITBD holiday.
This one.
Right. Complicated history, our two countries have.
Okay.
True.
I don't know if I am not an IT person by training. I'm A historian by training. I went to school for history and I ended up, it turns out there are no jobs for history unless you want to be a teacher. I'm terrible, like terrible with kids like that. Or you can be a professor or a writer. And frankly, I wasn't dedicated or smart enough.
Boo.
Mmh.
to do that. And I didn't really want to. So yeah, I know a little bit about it. It's strange because obviously we have fought both against and with each other in past conflicts.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's weird in a way.
So, as is our complicated relationship with most of the world, I guess. So.
True.
Yeah, I mean, we've been, what, colonized by multiple countries over the years. So it's not just you guys, it's even Spanish, Japan, what else? Even China.
Right.
What Spanish is weak?
So it started with China, and then it was the Spanish. And then we took from the Spanish when we were fighting the Spanish. And then the Japanese took from us during World War II. And then it turns out it's none of ours, right? I keep saying took from us. But it's all crazy, right?
Yes.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh.
It's us, it's ours.
Right. It's actually your country. But yeah, it's just I was looking at it. I was like, well, if they if they honor Memorial Day, do they honor the warden that we're fighting against them? That seems kind of crazy. So we just focus on the present. We focus on the more recent conflicts.
Mhm.
Yeah.
The.
Yes.
Yeah, and we're friends, we're friends now, so...
Uhhuh.
We're friends now. And you look at, you look at, I mean, as crazy as things are in the world, look at the US's relationship with Germany and Japan, right?
Allies, yeah.
Mhm.
very different. So anyways, strange, strange history.
We forgive it. It's weird if you look at it.
Yeah, that's a long story.
This is this is why I kick out the note takers, because Natalie would be like, what?
Yeah.
The **** is going on?
What are they even talking about?
What? This is client, if you guys had to submit, this is client the client relations portion of the meeting. Anyways, I digress.
Mhm.
We'll give it back to you, Ira.
Okay. All right. Thank you for that interesting startup call. All right, so yeah, it suits you. Hold on, I shared the wrong screen. Okay. I will share my screen now, I hope.
Yeah, good luck.
Yeah, Professor Marsh, right?
Shut up and get to work. Yeah, no.
You guys can see it? Let me know if you can't.
I can't.
We can.
Perfect. Okay. So once again, welcome to our bi-weekly service call. Our review duration would be from May 4th to 15th. Moving on to the next slide, we have the agenda items. So it's all the same from check-in to way forward. For the check-in slide, this is for you, Doug.
The stage is yours. Any challenges, anything you want to say to us?
No, I think we're good.
How is, I guess, question, how is Sheila doing? I know she was out sick for a couple of days and she's back now.
How is she doing?
Yeah, she's doing great. She has this acid thingy.
So she got this like years back. She loves eating coffee, sour food, so that's why she got this sickness. But now she's all good.
Got it.
I, yeah, I also, yeah, I see a reflux.
Massage reflux.
That is terrible. The few times that I've had that, it actually is one of the reasons I stopped drinking alcohol entirely for years. Now I'll have a little bit every once in a while socially, but if you get acid reflux a few times, it'll change your behavior quick.
Yeah.
Yeah, and it sucks. The feeling. Exactly, exactly, exactly. Everything that you intake, you just throw it up. So it's not an okay feeling. It sucks.
It's horrible. You feel, I mean, if you feel like you're dying, you feel like it's death. It's like a heart attack. It's terrible.
Yeah, no, it's the worst.
I had to be confined and be at the ER when that happens to me. And sometimes it's not even what you ate. Sometimes stress builds up and that's why it triggers it. Yeah.
For sure, yeah, yeah.
Now, for me, it's like very specifically like red wine, and I don't really like red wine that much, so that's fine, eliminated. But yeah, for people who suffer, I know that's really bad.
Not a good thing.
Eve.
Mhm.
He.
Yeah, that's a terrible feeling. But then, luckily, she's all good now. Oh, how about for Nigel? Anything?
No, no questions or concerns on my end. I mean, he just seems to be doing great. I worry that I'm not worried because he's such a machine.
Yeah, he is a really hard working guy. So we can move on to the next slide then. This is for the performance analysis slide. These are the IT by design recommended KPIs. You're already aware of this. So we can move on to the utilization trend and analysis. So this is for two weeks.
Yep.
The overall utilization doc, we closed it at 78.75. So if we're going to compare it from the last week, there's actually an increase for about 14.7%. So that's very good. And there were
There was just like a slight dip from this week, like from May 8th, 4th to 8th, because that was a slow week, I guess, was it?
Before to more four or five, I guess, but then I checked in with him and he was like just doing backup and server issues, that's why.
And then for the overall analysis, I can see here that we're moving on the right direction. Nigel's actually being utilized more compared to last week, and we're hitting the, we're close to hitting the target, the 80%. So way to go.
The.
For the ticket closure trend and analysis, we have here the target, it's 80%. I can see that the average resolution rate, we close it at 84. So we hit the target. That's very good. Comparing it to the last week's resolution rate,
There's like a 10% growth. So this time we did great. Plus the overall ticket closed ticket worked on ticket is about 101, comparing it to the closed ticket 85. So way to go to increase it.
we're actually leaning towards to closing more tickets. So we, so the average we wanted 80 to 90%. That was our goal for Nigel. So there was just a slight dip from May 13th to 14th.
week because he was not around. He was on a vacation leave for two days. So that's just one of the reasons. And yeah, he's been doing very good. I can't complain. Do you have any feedback or questions for this slide, Doug?
Nope.
Okay, let's move on to the CSAT. So I have two for this May. There was just one comment from Janet. She said that Nigel was right on time, quick and efficient. Very good. For the IT by design services, it's all the same. If you have questions,
let me know. For the way forward, Doug, we will continue to provide you with the services. And we want to ensure that every ticket, every interaction, every challenge will be catered. Plus, I can see that we've been more stable and the performance has been strong.
for the past few months. So I would like to ask you if we can move the bi-weekly recurrence to monthly. Is that okay with you?
Yep, fine by me.
I enjoy our interactions, but I agree.
Okay, perfect.
And it.
Yeah, it's time. It's time to do it once a month.
Yeah.
It's not you, it's me. It sounds like we're breaking up, but okay, fine.
Haha.
It's the sweetest way to say it, and...
That's okay. We just, we're in a, our relationship is in a different place.
Yeah.
Okay. Also, I just wanted to add here that both of our guys will be out on May 25th, right?
Okay, cool.
Yes, let me just confirm that I know that is true. I'm just looking at my calendar to.
Okay, let me know.
Oh yeah, that's the holiday. Yeah, we're all up. I'm sorry.
Okay, I'll let them know to mark it on their calendars. And then let's move on to the open Q&A. Anything you want to ask Doug, Andrea, anything you want to discuss here?
Uh, probably just with the...
How we, how we rate or how we gauge Sheila's performance, because I do know that currently we don't have that. Do you have any, or does HJ has any some sort of dashboard SLA metric first SLA interaction when it comes to the ticket, because it's how...
Sheila gets to have like a productivity. Was she able to work on that ticket once it comes in on your ticketing system? Or maybe, I know how many calls she gets, just so we have like a number on how we can actually gauge her performance. Yeah.
OK.
Yeah, I know AJ is working on updates to our phone system that including kind of being able to pull metrics and better routing. And so I think that we'll be able to at least pull something from there as far as like percentage of calls taken within, you know, what a reasonable amount of time, something like that.
Mhm.
Mmh.
Yeah, true.
Mhm, mhm.
And then I'd like to get into, like you're saying, something around the, you know, I know we have numbers as far as how long items sit in triage before they're dispatched as far as that SLA. So we can get you that one. And then I would love to get one around.
Yes.
like accuracy, like first try accuracy of like ticket entry where like are we capturing the issue and assigning it, you know, accurately the first time. But I'll get with AJ on how we're going to measure that one. So, but.
Mhm.
Gosh, do you guys use ConnectWise, right?
Yeah.
Gotcha. Do you guys select, I don't know, agreement?
Unconnect twice.
Oh, for sure.
Gotcha. So does that include also because I think there are some services wherein it's not even captured on that agreement, so it needs to be, I don't know, time and material maybe. Do you guys do that?
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, I think that also is, or can count as her KPI because, you know, if you're trying to bill it against an agreement wherein it's not even covered, then that's something that we also needed for her to understand so that she can go ahead and set those agreements properly in the next time.
Got it. Yeah, I think that's a good one too. Yeah, no, and I know people struggle with that. So.
Just a thought.
Yeah, that's my job before, Doug, before all of these. That's my job. Yeah, so I guess we can try to do that. I probably message AJ, is he in today or probably will be in next week?
Yeah, he's working today.
Gotcha. I'll probably just.
It's probably a good day. Yeah, it should. It's probably a good day to reach out to him. It's a little bit slow as far as stuff coming in, so we're trying to use it as a day to get caught up.
Fingers crossed.
I don't believe in superstition. So I say all sorts of really awful things like, oh, it seems like the weather's great. Nothing bad can happen today. It's not going to change it. The world doesn't revolve around me. I can, it might, I don't know. It might, I don't know. If it does, I deserve it because I do believe in karma to some degree. So
Oops.
What? How can it go wrong, Doug? How can it go wrong?
It.
The.
Same. But yeah, I'll probably reach out to AJ just so we can discuss it because it's been quite some time since she's got in. So we just wanted to make sure that we keep her, you know, engaged and she's improving daily.
Yeah, good.
Cool, I'll work with him then. Thank you so much.
Play it.
All right, well, thank you for enduring me, and I hope you both have a nice weekend, and I appreciate.
We're not breaking up, dog, alright, so I...
I appreciate the relationship that our two countries have formed over the years despite our turbulent start.
Yeah.
in history.
I don't know. I don't know. I don't speak. I don't speak for the US. So we're on our own.
Yeah.
It is.
By the way, have you registered to build it?
All right.
No, I haven't, not, I'm not sure if I'm going, but I'm, yeah, that's why I haven't registered.
We should go. We have a BOGO. Buy one and get one then.
Yeah, okay. All right, we'll see. I do, I do want to hang out.
Please register.
I am, I am fun at conferences.
See, you should be there. Come.
Too much fun.
Ring some, someone along, I don't know, maybe.
It's not far too, it's in New Jersey, so it's not bad for the New York, for the New York crew.
Exactly. Yep. I was told it's just the smell, so.
Alright.
It's just this smell.
Okay.
That's the reason why they are apprehensive in signing up. Any.
Yes.
I mean, New Yorkers are very snobbish about New Jersey, for sure.
Exactly, yes.
But I just feel that way about all city people. Like all of your cities are stinking and gross and disgusting. They're all the same to me.
Yes.
So.
Okay.
We all have our biases.
True. Anyway, I'll let you know once you were able to register. If you have any questions, please.
Appreciate it.
All right. Thank you, dog. Have a good day. Bye.
Right.
All right, thank you. Bye for now.
Thanks, ladies. Take care. Bye.